stuff what's up all right let's see
what's going on you know rolling just
gave you some love
meanwhile he puts the Rock's name in the
sauce the Babbitt rides with a lot of
stuff
stabbing we gotta hit up we gotta hit up
21 savage deep rock with the lyrics I'll
shoot everything walking I'm all
precision bad decisions taught the
language I'm talking I'm talking white
lines for the labels who said I never
turn heads and cypher dudes I leave on
scene because they once
[Music]
so I just posted their first Oh what's
up Wednesday morning
happy New Year to
friends out there Wednesday morning just
Liam did 11:41 got ton of sleep he
probably saw Rainey
video that I made of the flight couldn't
sleep last night did a lot of work in
motel room so mainly slept on this
flight
be uneventful flight just got some
season I have like seven to thirteen
substantial business fires which rarely
happen to me seven nights a year affect
me enough that I needs a requested right
away and couldn't a case one of the
reason they sleep so well is because I
only focus on positivity I don't let my
head gun who's interesting I was as I
wasn't able to sleep and I'm jumping
into form I'm like oh [ __ ] this is what
happens to everybody around everything
and no wonder nobody [ __ ] knows
everybody's staying up at night I'm
telling you I'm talented by the way the
reason I'm already in a good mood just
12 you know 12 hours later 24 hours
later positivity always will be this is
like I'm fast why do I start this
episode or end this episode with this
rant it's because I really think mindset
is everything and so you've got a really
desiring and positive about things and
negative things am i thrilled that I
have the ability to do things about it
to make what I'm worried about better or
my crippled by [ __ ] there's like these
set of things like tomorrow I always
choose positivity
look at other people around me it's not
just about me that winning they choose
positivity I look at the people around
me they're not winning that are not
pressing they're not advancing the
issues and negativity it's stunningly
binary it's stunningly black-and-white
it's stunningly merry
this is uh this is really up to you but
really to be very honest to be very
frank I think the biggest impact I'm
having is I beat up all the emails
already done last night as well is is
shifting that mindset and getting people
into that and making them understand
what they're in charge and hacking and
try to pour out the negativity dump the
negativity
the negativity I'm a positivity to world
that's what I'm pushing that's my agenda
and and that's why I think you're
feeling effects
in your partner and loved one business
partner in audience so many people get
49 comments for the even phenomenal ones
like you're a piece of [ __ ] and they
spend 80% of that one
Instagram
good morning good morning good morning
hello everybody had a few minutes here
caught up on work so figured I'd say
what's up 62nd Club good to see you all
so while I've got the thousand of you
October ninth Columbus Day actually blog
for you guys as well let's do this
double October 9th Columbus Day charity
wine event in New Jersey get your uber
'he's Connecticut New York and
Pennsylvania get your party buses if
you've got friends unbelievable day I'll
put a link here in YouTube for everybody
here go to winelibrary.com
right on the top it's the top banner on
mobile and desktop the super tasting all
the proceeds goes to the Crohn's and
Colitis foundation obviously means a lot
to me and my dad because AJ has Crohn's
disease I will be there a lot of people
are trying to figure out how to get a
selfie or hang out with me this is a
hundred dollar weight and with the
hundred dollars you get to taste 700
wines it's a ridiculous night babban
you're coming everybody's coming kind of
right from team Gary it's phenomenal
remarkable I really really really really
want you there Instagram appreciate all
the hearts that are coming right now
these super tasting make sure you're
there it's going to be lit just want to
take two last seconds before I sign off
right now so I just got a text that I
have to address back at the office this
community means the [ __ ] world to me
your likes and comments are my oxygen if
you're not subscribed to the blog get on
it we're really crushing dailyvee and
please keep tagging your friends in the
comments all this new awareness just
keeps feeding me
I don't need your money I move your
stuff I just I I just appreciate your
attention the admiration and your time
means means the absolute world to me and
I'm just completely refocused then
focused on that right now
period it's already over it's already
over it's already over the lake initial
push of like being one of those brands
now it's gonna be who's best and that
plays out over the next 24 months and to
be very frank with you Ryan I'm so
obsessed with the audio and being a
player in that like there's a lot of
things running through my mind I'm just
really looking at finances what I can
afford how could I do it I listen I want
to get together with you ASAP and like
give you my full brain dump you're gonna
be fired up we're gonna be [ __ ]
crushing but it's gonna be like I need
to do all the things that I got over the
next six three four to six months to
feel good about offense make sense just
got done with
we're in forward CEO of pure Wow calm
very amazing muttered a media company
publisher
female demo enjoying working with him
great dude one year in January very
focused on Boehner ex legislator media
the publishing world super exciting I'm
just gonna read a quick YouTube and let
me leave you with this a little youtube
comment make sure to comment and crew
want to get you guys on the show to 91
just got put up a little bit ago let's
see let's see what's going on ah first
comment I just turned 29
this whole clues your eyes into 29 is
incredible super excited about it
just turn 25 young as [ __ ] yes you are
Matt Lowe Burstein but geez the kid who
asked me for advice is like 16 the fact
that you're thinking about
entrepreneurship at that age is so
incredible daily because the reason I
started my own channel thanks Gary
I'm going through a really interesting
time you know it's a Jewish New Year now
reset you know some of us a little reset
twice a year with New Year's I actually
all of us with our different religions
and things that anyway nonetheless I'm
becoming unbelievable critically
unbelievably critical and auditing
myself on a daily micro but I'm very
passive and all bought into myself at a
macro this continues to be my theme
right micro speed macro patience I just
if I could do anything right now on this
whole 29:21 all these things that I'm
telling you to many of you are judging
yourself daily and and and and that's
coming at the expense of being patient
at a high level excuse me
too many of you said I'm sorry start
that again and keep it this way badly
because I like the stream of thought to
many of you are being passive daily but
judging yourselves by the years I'm the
reverse I'm judging myself every minute
here right now like I just let that
phone call go by and I'm like what I
just miss like every second Viper
but I'm patient at the macro which makes
me happy that's kind of like I'm trying
to really get this out of me like daily
daily daily speed
Laoghaire patience like there's
something here my friends that is at the
core of my success that I'm trying to
pass to you and in this shortened
episode I'm just gonna leave you with
that unbelievably passionate push one
more time and I was gonna be probably
series of three rants please [ __ ]
figure this out there's something here
[Music]
Babbitt rhymes with a lot of stuff
stabbing